خبرنا الرئيسي في هذه الجوله في حوالي
الساعه الثانيه عشر والنصف بتوقيت جرينتش
اعلنت اداره الطيران الفدراليه الامريكيه
انها تسعى للسيطره على عطل فني في نظام
الاشعارات الجويه اثر على عمليات الطيران
قالت اداره الطيران انا طلعت في كل انحاء
الولايات المتحده تاثرت بالاعطال في
النظام وانها طلبت من شركات الطيران ايقاف
كل الرحلات الداخليه
صور مباشره الان هذه بريتش ارز يبدو انها
تقلع من احد
المطارات لانه كما اسلفنا اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه الامريكيه اعلنت بانها
تستعيد السيطره تدريجيا على همم على نظام
اداره الطيران الفيدراليه ورفعت همم حظر
الاقلاع من مطارات كثيره بالعوده الى
تفاصيل ما حدث في حوالي الساعه الواحده
بتوقيت جرينتش اصدر البيت الابيض بيانا
قال فيه ان الرئيس بيضا
بالعطل انه لا دليل على وجوده هجوم
الكترونيا في هذه المرحله كما بيانات
وميلاحيه
لمواقع رصد حركه الطيران انا اجماليه عدد
الرحلات المتاخره داخل امريكا وخارجها بلغ
4000 وسبعه عشر
سبعه عشره رح 17 رحله جويه ونقلت وكاله
رويترز انا مطارات باريس الدوليه تتوقع
تاخيرا في رحلاتها بسبب الاعطال في انظمه
حواسيب الطيران الامريكيه وفي الساعه
الواحده والنصف اعلنت هيئه الطيران
الفيدراليه الامريكيه عن السنافر الرحلات
في مطار نور في نيوزي ومطار اتلانتا في
جورجيا ولا الطائرات الموجوده في الجو
بامكانها الهبوط بسلام انه تم احراز تقدم
في السعاده نظام الاشعارات بعد انقطاع
الخدمه وفي ساعه ثانيات بتوقيت جرينتش
اعلنت اداره الطيران الفيدرالي عوده
تدريجيا لحركه الطيران الطبيعه في عموم
الولايات المتحده تبعنا صور من مطار
رونالدو لط تتحرك على المدرج وفعلا هناك
يتواجد فادي منصور مراسل الجزيره فادي
اراك تنظر من النافذه في الخلفيه لطائرات
تتحرك همم ما المعلومات التي لديك
[موسيقى]
نعم جلال الان بعد الاعلان الذي اصدرته
اداره طيران
الفيدراليه حول استئناف اطلاع الطائرات من
المطارات في الولايات المتحده رغم انها لا
تزال تعمل على محاوله معرفه الخلل الفني
الذي ادى الى تعطل نظام اشعار الرحلات
الجويه بدانا نرى حركه يمكن ان تشاهد من
خلفي هذه طائره لاحدى شركات الطيران
الامريكيه يجري عمليه سحبها من قبل احدى
العربات على المدرج هذه ليست الطائره
الوحيده التي راقبنا انها تتحرك خلال
الدقائق القليله الماضيه منذ اعلان اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه لكن حقيقه جلال لم
نلحظ لم نرى ولم نسمع اقلاع اي طائره حتى
هذه اللحظه من مطار ريجن علما ان الحركه
في
المطار في المدرج بدات تتكثف العربات
المتعلقه بالعاملين خصوصا تلك المخصصه
لخدمه الطائرات يمكن ان تشاهد خلفي هنا
هذه البوابات الطائرات كلها مركونه هنا
هذه شركه طيران اخرى في الخلفيه بطبيعه
الحاله التي تشاهد العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن وعاده في هذا الوقت السماء من خلف
تكون مشغوله بحركه الطيران هذا هذا مطار
محوري هنا في هذه المنطقه هناك مطاران
يخدمان العاصمه واشنطن نحن في المطار
الاساسيه للطيران الداخليه وهو الطيران
الذي تاثر اساسا بهذا العطل الذي لا تزال
السلطات تحاول ان تعرف اسبابه وان كان
البيت الابيض حتى هذه اللحظه يقول
اللامراشرات على عمل متعمد او هجوم
سايبانيه الحركه مستمره حركه العربات التي
تخدم الطائرات التي ربما تنظم بعض
التحركات على المدرج لكن كما تشاهد همم
بكاميرا الجزيره ليس هناك اقلاع لاي طائره
بطبيعه الحال اداره الطيران الفيدراليه
اشارت الى ان عوده استئناف الرحلات بدا
بشكل تدريجي نحن نعرف انه على الاقل في
نيوجيرزي في مطار نيويورك وايضا في
اتلانتا في جورجيا قبل قليل جرس استئناف
عدد من الرحلات بسبب الاقتضاض الكبير
اداره الطيران فيدلاليه سمح باقلاع بعض
الطائرات لكن بما ان الرحلات التي تاخرت
هي تاخرت على مدى ساعات الاخيره الماضيه
هذا يؤدي الى عمليه اضطراب كبيره في حركه
طيران وبالتالي حتى وان كانت اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه لاعطت الموافقه والضوء
الاخضر ورفعت الحظر عن حركه الطيران
الداخليه للشروع في الاقلاع قد يكون هناك
مسائل داخليه تتعلق اولا بدخول المسافرين
مره اخرى الى الط باعاده جدول اي طائرات
سوف تتحرك وايضا اذا كانت هذه الطائرات
على سبيل المثال نحن هنا في مطار ريجن في
العاصمه واشنطن هذه الطائرات الذي سوف
تقلع من هنا اي ينبغي التاكد ان الوجه
التي سوف تذهب اليها سوف تكون مستعده
لاستقبلها بسبب هذا الاضطراب الذي حصل على
مستوى الولايات المتحده والذي قد يكون اثر
على نحو خمسه الاف رحله جويه وبالتالي
الامر قد يستغرق بعض الوقت حتى وان كان من
ناحيه اداريه وفنيه سمح للطيرات الطائرات
الامريكيه بالاقلاع لكن جدله هذه الحركه
قد تكون عمليه معقده وقد يشهد المسافرون
الامريكيون عمليات تاخير كبيره همم من غير
الواضح الى متى سوف تستمر وان كان كل هذه
الرحلات جرى تاجيلها لا نعرف اذا كان
بعضها عمليا سوف يتعرض ليس فقط للتاخير
ربما
لاعاده تنظيم الحركه اليوم على الاقل
فادي منصور من مطار رونا